hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and i'm ridiculously excited to
introduce you to dj pale face
absolute legend living legend right now
sat with me who's invested successfully
in property with the help of some of my
videos and support
and uh hey man great to have you in my
house thanks brother thanks so much for
coming down now
for anyone that doesn't know you i'd
have to give you a little introduction
because you've done some crazy good
stuff
so you wrote drake's most famous song
right
wrote the chorus yeah i'm called what's
the song called one dance one dance
amazing amazing tune by the way um
and it's just so cool like having you in
my house because i'm a mad fan of
your work your wife's work as well um so
you've been literally binging my videos
for the last couple years
yeah yeah they do help they helped me
hello a lot
um so yeah i was trying to get into the
property
um business a couple years ago um
we bought our house cash and i'm
i'm a very um i do a lot of research so
i'm doing all the research
going through the books i'm trying to
get my i'm trying to get my wife to
um come on board yep kyla so kyle is
very um
she's a pretty girl she doesn't really
do too much business or anything
when it comes to any business goes yeah
p deals with all of it blah blah blah
blah but there's always a conversation
that we have to have like
we always make decisions together yeah
so we were doing property i was like
right you need to understand this
because there's no point in me just
doing it and you not know what the
hell's going on
um property investment books um
property guide for beginners bloody
bloody blah
she's not going to read the books so one
night i said right kyle look at this
video here
look at this look at his geez he's going
to shout at you and blah blah blah blah
but at the end of it you'll you'll get
it and
she's watched it she's like he's he's
good you know
he's good to me do you understand it yes
i mean the same stuff i'm trying to tell
you
he summarizes it and you get it yeah i
get it cool
um and from that yeah i think i've i
think i followed you
i messaged you saying pick up on the
videos they
they do actually work and then since
that you've
gone i think he messaged me and said
keep doing the videos yeah regardless
how many views you get regardless of any
hate you get
yeah keep doing them because they're
really helpful they are helpful yeah
so yeah i'm glad you ca i'm glad you
cracked on um a lot of people you see i
don't know it's like a
like them things you see in tesco's
they'll come in there you're like this
is [ __ ] amazing
and then um and then it's gone so i was
like if this dude goes
then the information also you're gonna
have to find a different route to get
the information and it's not
like hmos the
the licensing things on the hmos to find
out just that piece of information
you've got to really go into a
specialist sector phone up a
solicitor phone at the council just to
find out
a simple question you've got to get a
big a big massive book
and start perusing through it and then
you're going to find a contradictive
piece of information
simply because the hmo law in
cambridgeshire is completely
different to the hmo ruling lincolnshire
and it's
dependent upon the councils and it's you
come on right you need this
that that that and blah blah blah blah
blah blah
all right that makes sense um so
basically phone the council yeah yeah
phone the council do the blah blah blah
blah blah blah
and it's just it's just concise so um
yeah that
those videos helped me get my misses on
board for me to start
investing into the property yeah and
you've done really well on the property
side you know you're a pr you're a good
negotiator
where's your investment patch um we are
doing um i wouldn't call it low
low cost um housing we are trying to do
affordable housing in areas for
for like workers um rather than
family homes simply because
that's the little that's the um area
that
we feel is going to be most set up for
our type of
investment we're looking at buying um
three bedroom four bedroom properties
but as cheap as you possibly can get
them
buy low rent high right yeah 100 man um
i would feel i would feel super
uncomfortable evicting the family
um i don't want to do that i don't feel
any badness for a victim someone that's
got a full-time job
and just refused to pay his rent um so
it's that section there um where we're
investing the properties go up
what we're buying about 100 and between
160 to 180k
um they're that the low yeah
they're like low the low three bedrooms
within that section
um there are some higher three bedroom
four bedrooms from about 250 to 300
within the same area
um but if you buy them what was 25
percent on
like a buy to let on 200 cases 50k down
minimum
um or probably 50 or 60k
and then you're gonna put in a nice
family that
if they do get furloughed or they get
blah blah blah
you're now forced into a position that
you don't really want to be in um
yeah um you get someone working at um a
factory for instance
i don't really feel too bad if i've got
to evict you um so that's
that's our that's our patch there we
know that evictions are going to come
and you don't want to do it but i i
couldn't evict anyone's kid and put them
out
onto the street so that's more of where
we're going to be
invest in our bits and pieces hmos um
but we've got hearts in it man so
yeah do you think there's a concept
though it's interesting you say that
that landlords and investors and
property people are greedy because i
don't think that's the case
at all you've seen people saying stuff
about me yeah
yeah but but but but i don't think
that's the case
at all i think that you're offering
homes to people you're in homes of
people um
right i'm not a greedy guy um you're not
you're not a greedy guy but i do know
lots of property investors that are
bloody greedy and they will not help
um uh right so i've been the music since
1998 yeah yeah i've known a couple of
property investors
since 1998 that have helped me within my
music career yeah
um at any given time they could have
gone
right see that 10 grand you just got
from that from that advance
slap it over here and i'll get you on
the property ladder i will run it
through my company
i'll go 50 you go 50 so therefore you
don't have to get the mortgage
they could have done that any at any
given time but they've chosen not to so
because of that and
they've helped other people out and
helped house them but not really helped
put them on that's effectively like
saying yeah i'll take your money and
i'll look like i'm giving you a good and
but really and truly i'm just seeing you
as a
potential income a lot of property
investors are like that
um but and i think that's where you get
the the bad brush you get labeled with
the same brush as
as as as the bad ones um with any
industry if
if look at the roman catholic church you
get a couple of priests doing horrible
things and then all of a sudden
the whole roman catholic church has got
the same brush as it and then
i guess to stop that happening if you're
educated in property yeah like you are
you know what you're doing you know buy
low rent high you know
suddenly people can't screw you over but
then in the same way
you're saying you don't want to screw
your tenants over you want to make sure
you're offering a good service
yeah um yeah talk to me a little bit
about the because you've been quite
fortunate about i guess probably not
fortunate maybe you just work
really hard to get there but you've
you've made a lot of money in
in music and and then that's enables you
to then invest
yeah um and that's the case you know
sometimes people that
some of my students or people that come
on the show they've made a lot of money
in business or music or whatever
you call prs prs yes see to me prs is
something different
to me prs is that's my lifeline man um
yeah
yeah where's prs prs performing right
society it's basically publishing
um so it's the music it's
the uk's um company which distributes
publishing to writers so effectively if
you if you write a song
um you don't even have to perform the
swings write the lyrics down write the
melody down and give it to someone
every time that song gets performed on
radio tv or broadcasted
in a shop um that shop has to pay pr is
a license fee and depend upon how many
times your song been played which one
oh well well well well this the the big
the big one the big one
maybe just for anyone that doesn't know
what what we're talking about you'll
know the song
all right so that's up there this is a
good song bro
it's a decent song i can't complain i
can't complain
so that was the first that was the first
song to reach a billion streams on
spotify
um the guinness book of records um
it's how does it feel to have written a
song that's gone down that bit and have
drake
singing it it feels weird it feels
it feels weird at the time it felt weird
um the whole
way it came about was weird um it was a
sample clearance so we cleared the
sample
um even when we cleared the sample um
because at the time there was there was
there was my label northerland records
and there was another label
defender zelloesta my friend corey runs
um
and we originally put out the the the
funky house version
back in the day so we needed to clear
the the mechanical copyright um
which the label owns so i went down to i
went down to birmingham where corey
studio is
and was going back so we signed it off
and i was like we sent we sent it over
and we like looked at each other and was
like where's that it
was like yeah we signed us we had a
little drink still didn't feel real
then on i think on the tuesday um drake
released it
and we saw it enter the charts and it
was like what the what the hell's going
on there
went to number one stayed there um which
was really really strange
because um when right so when drake
released that song there was it was the
c it was the lead single
off of his album which wasn't app which
he hadn't had now map for at least two
years
so everybody was waiting for like this
drake album to come out yeah
so they finally said yep i'm going to
release it as the first single
but it wasn't just the first thing it
was the first thing when there was a
there was another single on the same day
it
came out so you had see a drake
featuring kylo ren wizkid which was our
one
and then you had drake featuring kanye
west and jay-z
on the same day yeah so the so the kanye
west and jay-z one in america went to
that number one in the charts and then
the one dance was at number
26 and [ __ ] so he was like mmm
that's a bit like why they released the
kanye the [ __ ] kanye west one kanye's
is massive
right so it was like ah and then
it switched around so it was like i
started overtaking the kanye west like
means
drake wizkid and kyla was more
successful than drake kanye western
jay-z like the [ __ ] so you're thinking
oh what's this all about um yeah it
still doesn't feel
real um we um
so that was just in our house um the way
prs works as well let's say for instance
um
it gets paid on the radio today you've
got to wait at least
six months for it to hit prs and then
come back we've screwed you up a bit
though in terms of mortgageability right
yes because even though you're making
great money yeah the lenders are
thinking
it's not stable yeah it's yeah that's
what
so um initially we said right we're
gonna
we're gonna buy a house yeah
everything's gonna buy a house um we'll
put down a hefty deposit so i said right
we'll put 100k down it's going to be
100k and have 200k on the mortgage
so we got to the 100k mark the phone at
the bank so i want to get the mortgage
banks asked for all these so much stuff
because they've said we're self-employed
they're wanting to see
our company accounts for the record
label company accounts for the
publishing company
want to see are our accounts
um three years accounts essay 302 then
they want a letter from your accountant
saying that you're going to be capable
of earning a certain amount of money so
don't jump through all these hoops
and then they go right um unfortunately
you've been declining the mortgage
um this took about three months at that
stage we'd raise another 100k
so like what about if we give you 200k
and we just bought a 100k mortgage like
they were like okay we'll run it again
declined again so we had to buy the
first house outright um so we
i think i think the first house was
through it was on 300k
plus the stamp ge i forgot what the
stamp duty was
um and so we got on that
and so we brought it out right
we felt good and then we had another
100k stacked up
um so we bought our first buy to our
first buy to let
um bought that outright as well and
then two three years passed got an essay
302 now
and you've got high income for the past
three years
um what's really annoying is when we
first went for the for the more to be
the santander he said right
based upon your current income we can
offer you a mortgage up to like 3.5
million pounds
guys all we need is three years of
accounts so
it it it does mess it up it really
messes up you know what though
because when i as we joke about when i
hear prs i think
private rented sector yeah right you're
talking about your royalties from your
music but
you put your prs money into prs yeah
right into the private rented sector
which then gives you a stable income
income which then makes you more
mortgageable so over the last couple
years you've now managed to
start you know getting better leverage
on your
finances yeah which is great um what
makes your question
why did you choose because you're making
you're making a lot of money off of the
song still are which is great
why did you choose property and not gold
silver stock shares bitcoin business
like why
why property all right so bitcoin
i saw someone died and died with the
encryption key so everyone that
invested into a particular bitcoin
couldn't get them so that was locked
stocks and shares it's volatile market
um
you can put it's it's gambling um
i've done stocks and shares a little bit
even before we had the whole money
coming in and every time i
went on the stock student shares i've
just seen my my thing crash out i think
the last one we've done was debenhams
debenhams crashed um down this toilet
paper company called akro
that made a little bit money bit crashy
like
i'm gonna have to watch the news i'm
gonna have to get
undercover spies in all these companies
and everything to try and find out what
their
their next quarter four's gonna be
looking like and then and then
that's too much that's too much hassle
um gold i was thinking about doing the
gold thing um
we bought we bought a couple of um gold
bullion coins because
obviously there's no capital gains tax
when he passes seen as currency
it's a good way of saving money but it's
not a good way of making money
um like if you've just got a million
pounds
and it's liquid cash in your bank
account buy gold with it
because it's not going to devalue is it
it's always going up it's going up at
the same rate as inflation
sure so cool
if you want to save money for a rainy
day if you want to make money
um i don't know any other
business where you can get all right you
put
30k down and you're going to be getting
about 500 pound a month for the 30k
you put 30k into an isar we can only put
20k into an icer can't you
but if you put 20k into an isr unless
you're doing
stocks and shares ice over the next 25
years doing compound interest and
getting for
480 grand 408 grand which compounds up
to a million pounds
and you've got to be consistent putting
the 20 in every single year
that's cool but that's not really as you
say financial freedom
because you you're required you're
required to put 20k
in every single year so although it's to
make myself it's more of a liability
property is the only real thing in my
opinion where
if you if i put 50k down now then
in five years time that 50k is still
there
but that 50k has made me what seven
thousand pound a year so it makes
it back yeah yeah i don't know any other
thing that can do that from investing um
you could invest into public into music
publishing um
but you're at the mercy of companies
like spotify bbc radio playlist and blah
blah blah there's a lot of money
involved in
music publishing um
but it's effectively gambling as well um
for example when i originally wrote do
you mind
we i went and done a publishing deal
with uh
emi a girl called amber davis down at
emi
and it's it was for
five thousand five thousand pounds and
they get fifty percent of your
publishing going forward
now to sign that tune to emi for five
bags at the time
it's one of however many changes you
can't see where it's going to go
so in order for in order for me to make
money from publishing i would have to go
out and spend
five thousand pound each time on lots of
tunes which
potentially could do something great in
the future but it's not a sound
investment you haven't got
you can't say okay well in a year's time
what's going to be the return of
investment
you can see that if you go and buy big
publishing tunes like and i say when i
bought outstanding from the gap band for
instance yeah
you can you can say right well let me
see your statements for the past 10
years
you've made that much money that much
money that much money so therefore
because it's a legacy tune we estimate
it's going to move that that that
so i'm going to give you 300k i haven't
got 300k to go and give someone's
publishing
um on the on the hope that it's going to
still generate
i have got 300k to put into a property
because i know that in three years
time i'm going to take out 310k from
that property
um plus whatever rental income's been
coming into it
um and if it all goes if it all goes
tits up
you just sell the lot and you walk away
with all your money at the end of the
day
if you can show me another business
which does that
and it's passive income like barring
a roof breaking down or getting a leak
in your house it's there's not really
much you have to do especially if you
get a decent estate agent to become a
manager you give
you make a good deal with them um
there's nothing to really do is there
man no i mean i'm i'm with you
100 um you've got you've got bricks and
mortar
yeah it's it's not you can't get taken
it can't get stolen no
shortage of houses overpopulation of
people you've got your capital
appreciation and your cash flow coming
in from the rent
i love property and i think it's really
great that people like you are not only
investing successfully in property but
also
speaking out about it yeah you know
coming on this sort of show and saying
look this is what i've done this is how
it's worked out for me
because there's a lot of people i mean
we've got a lot of mutual connections as
well right no i know
a lot of mutual connections and there's
a lot of people in the music industry
that are making very good money but they
don't know what to do with the
with the investment you know they don't
know how to invest it
they're scared that if they try and do
it on their own they might mess up and
some people do mess up if you've got
educated
and you've done it well um but you can
lose money on property yeah you can
you can like what about those ones that
have um
the new builds that um they've had
they've done something dodgy with um the
planning and stuff you're talking about
even the cladding um
i think it's something these whole
issues no bradford they've there's
there's there's a fault they didn't do
something in the you know it happens or
there's all those toxic waste and yeah
all the time said that the mortgage
company said that your property is now
valued at zero
so that means you can't you can't sell
it right
but you have to keep paying back the
mortgage yeah and if it gets condemned
and you can't live there
so yeah you can get done like that um
yeah
don't want to be doing that new builds
are possibly the worst investment ever
yeah and the worst overseas
offshore off plan and it's the stuff
that a lot of these um
you know people in the music industry
get roped into because they see the
fancy design of what it looks like they
wanted to be shiny
and nice at the end and they go oh i'll
bite and they end up buying something
overpriced
yeah that could have serious issues with
it more time shared ownership as well
yeah like it's crazy um
you'd be better off just going to an
estate agency
um or watching a few youtube videos and
doing it yourself
yeah then going to some of these you
know packager companies
it's the same with the with the ifas you
know independent financial advisors
they put you into some right bad schemes
i know it's all commission based
and it's actually terrible i'm like no
just just go through an estate agent
and invest in property or if you want to
be really smart learn about hmos
and development and buy refurbished
refinance get a little bit of education
or team up with somebody
but um you know you've really it's
you've worked hard for that money
you have so you want to invest it smart
you have to invest in smoke
you can lose it all you can lose at all
um
a lot of people in music make a bit of
money and they end up
lose losing a lot i had a friend that
had two properties
um two properties two cars couple of
studios
and he lost he lost a lot um
was living well i think he's living in
accommodation now
and i'm like dude you had you had
everything what the [ __ ] went wrong
no you know you mean i don't i don't
know like you tell me
wasn't managed properly um had his
friends living in the houses they didn't
want to evict his friend
um our first property we had one of our
friends living in they didn't pay the
rent for two months
i was like mate you've got to come out
he turned his phone off to go to the
door knock the door down
i think this was the time he wasn't
evict anyone either right so i was like
mate you shouldn't be here right you'll
pass the day you've got to come out the
house
where am i going to go i don't give a
[ __ ] like you can sleep on my couch but
i can't allow you to stay in my house
it's scary though it's it's like in
people's prime
foot i see it with footballers they're
making crazy money and then they're
pushing boxes and sainsbury's ten years
later i know
and it's just scary i think it happened
to i'm daley and atkinson he's the
aston villa player and when he died he
was didn't have much at all left and he
was like premiership player in the 90s i
could buy one champ man in 93 it was
like day in atkinson getting in my team
and so what were your top tips then for
someone looking to invest in property
what are your top tips top tips for
investing in property i would say
um
i would say find a good estate agent um
i think that's
vital um find a good estate agent that
can have an honest relationship with
because because estate agents as you
probably know can end up pressuring you
to buy things which
are not good um everyone's got an agenda
bro
everyone's got an agenda everyone's got
an agenda um we went through four estate
agents up
find a good estate agent and find a good
solicitor not a call center solicitor
yeah
find the decent solicitors um we've had
we bought three four properties now um
one fell through as well someone pulled
out on us
and the solicitors hold things up um
there's a dodgy company which has got a
call center in um
southport and the call center incentives
yeah where i'm sitting i was in
huntington
and so going back and forth with this
girl and
her language just feels a bit definitely
non-solicitor format yeah
so what does that even mean nonstop
like she just feels like she's one of my
son's friends yeah so
okay i've googled her name on facebook
yeah and i see
mutual friends i'm like right i actually
recognize you actually used to come to a
couple of the nights i used to play at
right so i've seen that age it's like 22
i'm like one minute this guy
she's 22. she can't be a solicitor
her phone that states me this dc law
company yeah
they're not really solicitors are they
they're like they are
they just do property of that if i'm
asking any questions you ain't got a
clue i'm talking about
worse than that i'm firing up the there
are our mortgage
people um the mortgage works and they're
telling me something completely
different to what this girl's telling me
the girls five hours back and forth that
people want to complete
um so we scrapped all those solicitors
we found a really good one
um they're off the radar they're not
they're not on the high street i would
say if you want to solicit take them off
the high street
try and find a solicitor that
specializes in property
investment as opposed to a mix of
everything because then you're going to
get decent solicitors in there which
actually
know what they're talking about um the
last solicitors we had
any any um anything um a search comes in
they're on the phone can you pay for
this search now please pay for that now
i'm getting my kid from school mate
but we need to pay for the search now
the solicitors we've got now
we don't hear nothing from them until
the day before completion
there's your searches there's this
there's that there was a problem here
but we've rectified that
you know right and it comes on a nice it
comes on paper like doesn't come with
pdfs and [ __ ] it comes all on paper very
professional
um save you a lot of time and headache
good
as good estate agents and um
i would say wait don't unless you're
buying for
residential purposes for yourself
don't rush out and buy the first
property you see yeah
wait for wait for the property to be on
the market for six months
until the or or have three or four
options
yeah you know the first it is the first
time you see an investment you have an
opportunity
you could be like oh wow that's much
better than even in the bank or that's
much better than this and you go for it
but it's better to actually think well
what are my options let me look at a few
different
properties um but uh you're
basically what you've said it kind of
all comes down to power team yeah it's
about your team
and i think your net your network is
your net worth
yeah yeah definitely definitely
definitely
um look at the whole the whole one dance
situation like
network made it completely gave us loads
of money coming in
and that happened fast as well didn't it
bro really fast man um they phoned on
the friday
and the song was released the following
tuesday um
life-changing life-changing um i was
saying i was um i was training to be a
train driver before that
bloody hell changed to be a train driver
yeah so so this
so this happens i'm thinking to myself
right i haven't quit train driving yet
so i'm thinking
if i can just delay my course by six
months and drop back into another course
yeah
then it gives me six months to um deal
with [ __ ] air
make sure she doesn't get ripped off and
then knit back into a nice
high paid job um so i phoned up the
train driving people
i hate lying i can't lie yes i said look
um
my message they didn't want to get
towards my missus she's got something
happening with her career
it's a life-changing opportunity and at
the moment
for at least the next two to three
months i'm going to be required to be at
home with the kids
and to do the train driving company goes
to me goes mate
you need to get rid of her you know
she's going to [ __ ] up your life you're
walking out enough
wow like that's the trains um
so yeah quit trains and
best move i've done just quitting the
trains um
it was scary because up until the point
i became a train driver i'd be
completely
relied upon music and
when you live hand to mouth so to speak
for so many years
when you get your first two and a half
grand comes through every four weeks
you're like
that's all right you know like there's
two and a half grand there now and
there's gonna be two enough ground there
next month i haven't got off
stand outside the club waiting for the
promoter to make not run off with the
money and that sort of stuff um
this is all right so we just got into a
bit of um security
that we we got our first bed on hp like
everything before we buy cash so we've
got our first bit of security got a car
on our finance as well and then it was
like right
you tune's at number one what are you
gonna do
and you haven't got time to
go well let's see how it pans out it's
like no because the opportunities are
now
anything that's gonna get done is gonna
get done over the next six months
and if you're not on it you know how the
music industry works someone's gonna
[ __ ] over your misses and it's gonna end
horribly wrong yeah um so it was quick
um so i quit hard decision so
as i said i said to kai i said look kyla
i don't know what to do you know to me
but what i do know is
if i smoke weed again i can't go back to
the trains in it so
and i do want to smoke weed again um so
i said [ __ ] it i'm going to smoke a
spliff
and that sort of like solidifies my
decision into like not going back to the
trains because if i get tested
i'm going to get sacked and you get
tested you burn the bridges with a job
i burnt the bridges man was this just
was this just after you released the
song
the big one this was yeah this was two
weeks so surely you're not gonna need to
go back to trains after
after hitting number one and staying
working so long well
in the olden days you wouldn't um but in
this day and age
um bear into consideration in the olden
days it was um
it was vinyl cells cd and cassette yeah
yeah so first we could release
you go to woolworth's w.x smiths you go
in there and the singles
a pound yeah yeah week two it's four
quid right so week two the company start
making their money and that's four
pounds it only costs
like 70 p to make up so it's three
pounds seventy profit so you're getting
even if you was on like ten percent
you're making
a nice bit of that now every time it
streams you're getting 0.002
right so does that mean if i cause i
don't put ads on my channel
yeah okay on my youtube channel i don't
tend to yeah if i put a song
on my channel it's not my song what
happens is they force me to put ads on
the channel
and then they give the profits to the to
the person that wrote the song yeah
so that means if on this on this video
if i played the song
technically you're gonna you're gonna
earn something yeah i'll get 18.75
percent over there
about 100 um passive
though right it is passive income um but
you don't know you don't know how long
it's going to last exactly or how much
it's going to be
you don't there are valuation companies
which can go out and they can look at
your
um they can look at your accounts your
prs income priorities i'm
england bmi and uh
and your i'm with sony on this do you
mind one
um so they can look at your statements
for the past five years and they can
give you a valuation of
how much your publishing is worth um so
i think my catalogue was worth 1.2 mil
last week and within the music world
you've got different companies which um
do royalty financing
or they will buy your publishing off you
out of multiple
so there's uh so rorty finance i'm i'm
literally about to do a right financing
deal at the moment
just so we can clear the back end of the
mortgage on our residential so
we're unencumbered free up some more
funds and invest in some more buy to
let's
so we do that over five year period um
we pay back
20k a quarter um and the interest rate i
think it's
six point five percent interest rate
over five years um
on a 400k loan if we pay about 480.
now we worked out that's 80k interest if
we use that to pay off our mortgage
um our mortgages i think we've got 320k
left and left on the mortgage um over 29
years you pay off 280
k in interest though we do the right
financing thing to
pay that off free up our to have our
cash flow back so to speak
um so that's what you're financing which
which is really really really good
any interest you pay you can tax write
off you can deduct it against your
against your income right when you when
you someone buys your publishing
um you get a lump sum you don't
receive any publishing again for the
rest of your life of whatever you
you've sold for them and more time it's
going to be
for a big amount so you're going to pay
45 income tax so whatever you sell for
you basically divvy up half of it and
then then you get so you
can either take the take the choice you
can have a lump sum now
or you can just have a dripping yeah i
want to talk about diversification
see i get a lot of people that come to
me that are making good money
doing their thing you know football
music whatever and i
i always advise don't stop that for
property
push that like crazy do that like crazy
because that's what that's what's making
the big bucks
however you want you want to have money
making
money investing yeah and money
preservation yeah so you want to have
you want to have the three things going
on
yeah i mean what do you what do you
think about that i think it's great i
think um
uh don't put all your eggs in one basket
yeah it's it's
it's that um if
you get a dip in one of your income
streams like you always do
um that's that can't have a knock-on
effect in the way that you live your
life
if you've got a table with one leg it's
dangerous yeah
i mean now you've got you're in a
situation where you've got your prs
coming in you've got the opportunities
to maybe do the the cash in or the
whatever great that's cool that's one
that's a tree trunk that's strong it's
unlikely that that's gonna stop making
money
but then now you've got your capital
appreciation from your properties wealth
preservation but you've also got your
cash flow
yeah so you're in quite a good place now
good it's good place to be
um uh i try and
it's the asset and liability column it
is
you don't want to have one asset and
then have all the other all the other
liabilities
if you're if your asset is publishing
that can't be your only income because
if something goes wrong with that
publishing world
you end up getting [ __ ] over um
property if you've got everything
invested in property and then all of a
sudden
or one type of property should i say not
just property but one type of property
let's say all your properties with hmos
and then the government goes right
new law comes in as from tomorrow and
your hmo
licenses are lost you're gonna have to
re-think your whole strategy
you're wiped out or not wiped out but
you couldn't wipe you out
i agree if you had a couple of service
accommodations
um a couple ones that you're buying
fixing up and gonna sell and make a
profit
then that you've diversified your income
stream um
if i'm a publisher and i'm signing
people's publishing and all of a sudden
um
at the moment i don't know uh we've got
this last time r kelly's publishing five
years ago and
that was our bread and butter and then
he gets disgraced
which is really strange um because the
whole r kelly thing came out
when i was a kid and everyone knew about
it i don't know why he's getting
disgraced now for
but then you get disgraced all your all
your income stream goes downhill because
you've
because you've um your [ __ ] was based
upon r kelly
but had you signed r kelly's publishing
a bit of gospel music
some church music over there done some
advert music or signed a little
catalog over there for that one one big
thing goes down
you're still gonna you're about being
entrepreneurial i guess it's about
having the knowledge but also having the
persistence
because because everything takes hard
work yeah you know to win in
any industry whether it be property
whether it be music
whether it be sports business you've
gotta
know what you're doing and then you've
got to follow through yeah and i think
people don't want to put the graft in
sometimes
it's just it's graft broth like um the
first property we try to buy a buy to
let
glad we did it now we was going for a
leasehold
um and this woman
about two weeks before completion starts
flipping out saying that our lawyers are
[ __ ] up the process
phoned me up screamed down the phone at
me and then pulled the deal i was like
all right now if i let that i had to pay
to pay out so this is
you get stung a little bit now my
message was pissed she's like oh we just
lost the grand i can't believe we've
lost the grand
and this house is never gonna happen
blah blah blah i'm like blaze man look
at this one silly woman yeah
um we'll find a better house we'll find
a free old
didn't really want to do a leasehold but
it was a good location
but we're going to get a free old um i
think we found the house two weeks later
for
15k more expensive but three old on a
high street better area
one bedroom house like which doesn't
really exist um
you've got downstairs and upstairs one
bedroom upstairs a little bathroom
perfect little spot and it and it and it
worked out um
if you're not persistent yeah and also
you've got to be patient because things
take time sometimes
yeah you know things take time and and
sometimes i'll have a property i'll have
my offer accepted but it's it's
three or even six months later before
i've got the keys yeah and if
it's the first time around you're
thinking what's going on is this normal
is there something wrong with me or
actually no she's just perfectly normal
yeah um
so you you're a pretty good negotiator
as well you've uh and i talk about
negotiation a lot but you're pretty good
give us some negotiation tips i'm a bit
harsh when it comes to negotiating that
um
i always think um
if i'm selling my house um
well up until the point i'll sell in my
house when i sold my house it sort of
confirmed what i already thought yeah
um we're selling our house and they said
we're gonna put on the market for three
two five
with the the target of getting 310 i was
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah cool so then to me
anything i see on rightmove or zoopla
whatever it is
i'm deducting the stuff so yeah exactly
so i go around
um we're only buying in one area at the
moment um we know the area very very
very well
misses us to live there all our life so
we know the houses and whatnot
so we see a house i think the last one
was on for 180.
so i said right so this house is not
worth a penny more than
one six five to me i'll make i'll make
an offer
but tell him he doesn't accept the offer
the next time i come back round
and i will come back round it's not
going to be that it's going to be 10k
lower
all right so good technique it's good
technique yeah so you say look 165 now
yeah but but listen if you don't accept
it i'm gonna i'll come back in two weeks
and it'd be one five five yeah and you
can't you can't be upset mate because
you've you've had the
you've had the opportunity you've had
the warning yeah and if you want to be
greedy
like and hold out for someone else to
come along
do your thing um uh but i'm not waiting
around i'm not waiting around because
um at the moment i've got that money set
aside it's gonna potentially take like
you said
minimum two months two and a half months
minimum
um on average it's about four to five
months because especially that
the like time that we're in now um yeah
um my mate said to me um cash is king in
property
if you're if you've got if you've got
the funds and your cash buyer and blah
blah blah blah blah
you negotiate because that's the way
that the whole
yeah the whole market is set up i'm
trying to get you at the moment to step
into development right
yeah i thought that's my next uh i'm i'm
scared i'm scared like we've got
something like one of our properties
that we've got to get fixed at the
moment we can't find a roofer um i've
been looking for roof for two weeks so
yeah
it's all but again it's all about power
team like you said earlier very true
so you might have managed to get a good
power team you've done the training
you've watched the videos you've got the
experience
yeah you're educated in terms of broker
solicitor accounts and all that stuff
it's no different when you move into
development and yes as soon as
when you have a good team suddenly you
don't have to worry about um
you know who's going to fix the roof and
who's going to yeah you've got a great
teammate from stuff yeah
that's that's my next steps probably
getting like the team now yeah
for sure and as i say you know you know
you know i got you on that on that
side what what made you agree to coming
down
and being on the show well what made me
agree to come down for this show here
um i don't do show i don't really speak
out or anything um
i like your content um i like the fact
you cast off alan sugar i thought yeah
yeah this guy's real man um you saw what
happened with that he was wrong no he
took the piss he took the piss um
i don't like people getting the piss
taken out of
um i think uh
i've learned from what you've said and
i've taught
i've made that make sense to my missus
as well um
you've asked me to come down to your to
your show i felt honored to come down
and speak about property
i normally i think the last thing we've
done was about sample interpolation on
my friend's show um so i don't really
speak out that that
that much but um it's sense it's
objective
there's a purpose behind it i already
know
that these videos when they go out there
are people out there which do learn from
my friend t2
um i spoke to him yesterday i spoke to
for like a while
he's like yeah what's going on man
where's me yeah same old stuff to me but
i'm going to go and look at samuel lee's
tomorrow he goes wow i went to one of
his seminars man like he's
he's on point bruv i'm like yeah he's on
point um
i'm gonna go down lincoln marvin
flipping trains him
like from when marvin says you're cool
brother like
you're cool with it man um and t2 he's
the guy
i know his song massive heartbroken
heartbroken
broken bartoon yeah yeah he was at the
crash course yeah the crash course yeah
nice
he probably wouldn't come and speak to
you direct um he's very much
if i came to your crash course i
probably wouldn't have come and spoken
to you um yeah because the big court
they're big there's a lot of people
there yeah
and um you have to connect to me up
there i'll have chat with them yeah but
they're but um different personalities
as well like we've been um
like i've got um um i've got asperger's
yeah which means um
we don't like probably from this
interview i don't make eye contact um i
don't uh
i think very logical i'm very not
emotion based in making my decisions and
blah blah blah
so i had to come and that also gives you
a sense of social anxiety as well
which sounds really strange me being a
dj and doing what i'm doing but
social and social anxiety um when i was
like
12 i used to start a hell of a lot
certain words are but
it won't come up properly so that feeds
it all as well
um i think a lot of thinkers uh
i've got asperger's um asperger's
syndrome
um so i think that when it's someone
when it's someone that is talking sense
they've got a purpose behind it
i can see there's some some [ __ ] going
on with you which is not
[ __ ] necessary um it's like no i'll
definitely go down there
you've helped me out do what i'm doing
you've helped out a load of other people
when i'm speaking to other people
they're like yeah i know that guy blah
blah blah and then i saw marvin
training you as well you seen you seem
cool brother like
why would i not because marvin's my
personal trainer yeah
you go back a long way with him yeah
you've done music together you actually
produced his
785 girl which is absolute banger which
was mental because i heard that radio
one
i know i was i was mad right because
that wouldn't exist
had i not been browsing the instagram
and see what i said well that's marvin
it's me
dude that's marvin it's me he's a sick
singer as well
i don't know he sang so from that we um
we reconnected um so you rejected marvin
because of men why are you yeah
and then wow so i never knew that yeah
so then i said we should do a tune
together he's like yeah i've got a song
sent me the acapella over i've done a
new mix of it he said it was an old tune
he got no intention of doing anything
with it
and then pushed it out and started
getting paid on kiss i think i think mr
jam played
on radio one um some i think it was
um urban anthem one summer dance anthem
whatever it was
um unfortunate because we're in locked
because this whole third life is no
clubs available anymore but
that would be a banger in the club i
know i know that would have been amazing
no
i know but yeah it's been pretty cool
man so it's been a ride
yeah it's it's just great to um i mean
i'm successful in property but i always
said when i become successful in
property i'm going to share it i'm going
to teach others
same thing with music man um same thing
with music i've been trying to
help people for the longest time try and
get them
to know about prs know about ppl know
the different
different licenses different rights what
you should and shouldn't
sign and just helping people out um
i think sharing them sharing their
knowledge i've had people come up to me
10 years later and go pee you really
help me out i'm like
dude i don't know who you are yeah
because don't remember you told me to do
this and done that
i've done this and then i got this deal
um a kid that um
in 2004 you used to come up to the
studio give him some remixes
show him some bits and pieces he's doing
the walker's crisp advert now he's doing
um remixing for cigar off some mad
at some he's in advert music which pays
crazy money man
um like licensing for like 75k per
per advert and you're like dude you've
done really well goes yeah man i moved
to bristol come out of london
i'm down there now don't really [ __ ]
with anyone too tough anymore everyone's
a [ __ ] that's doing my advert work
good on you mate man um but it was that
knowledge from your id library music
we do his music here we sent to the
company it sends out all over the world
and you might get a theme tune
you might get a wrestler walk down with
your tune one day that's really exciting
i
i love wrestling yeah it was wwf and see
some all kind of your music
that's my [ __ ] song for my [ __ ]
song yeah so you get different little
things but it's when you
when you give someone the knowledge and
you see
them use that knowledge and apply the
knowledge and it's and it's directly
because of
your instruction um
suppose that's why i was attracted to
teaching as well it's like
help um at christmas time do you like
seeing people open the gifts that you've
got them and be really happy or do you
like getting the gifts coming in
because i like it's better to give than
to give in it's always better to get
yeah um
when we get when we're doing the
christmas shopping i'm like yeah kyle
let's figure out let's just get everyone
else
like i don't really care if i don't open
anything i've got my studio like i don't
what i'm gonna do oh pass the pigs or
something stupid like that
um but it's seeing other people's
reactions it's seeing
what you can do for other people um like
just helping it makes me feel good uh
i know there's a lot of other there's a
lot of people which by
re by um uh suspending someone's
progress makes them feel good
um as a lot of people like that i was
um especially the music industry was
coming back in the car one time
there was there was a car full of djs
mcs and whatnot yeah
um was was like driving up i think the
giggles in ipswich driving up to it
which was two cars on the way up there
this
driver was swerving all over the motor
whales i'm not getting your car away
back no [ __ ] way mate
so we all jumped into my friend's car i
said about
seven people in this car and if for some
reason was upset on the on the night
and i remember there was me there was my
there was my cousin that got a job at
island records ruling back in the car
my mate daniel and and he's driving the
car i won't say his name because
he'll know exactly who he is he's
driving the car and he goes that's it
because none of you like none of you
are gonna make it they move the industry
before me none of you and i thought
bro you're all you've just said that you
that none of us are going to make it
before you
so that means that anything that comes
in you're going to hold up and
you will definitely not see us go
forward
um yeah when you get that around you
yeah um it's not that's not a good
friend no it's not my friend is someone
that wants you to win
yeah not someone that wants you to fail
i know and also as well like
i only want to be around people like
yourself that that want to build other
people up not to let people down
yeah there's too many people that try
and tear other people's tower down to
make themselves feel better and it's
just wrong
it's wrong man it's wrong like i'm all
about building people up but you're
doing that by coming on this channel
because you're going to inspire people
in property
maybe people even in the music industry
or whatever you're gonna see your story
and think man if he can do that i can do
that yeah well hopefully man hopefully
um
i will say that the knowledge then it's
the knowledge um
for instance um the three years accounts
anyone that's a musician
if you've got if you've got the deposit
to get a mortgage yeah
biggest advice to you is go out get a
stupid job for three months
get three months pay slips and then go
to the bank and get a mortgage based
upon those pay slips it doesn't matter
how much is in your account
they're going to lend to you based upon
how much tax you're paying them blindly
um but that's again that's finding a
solution instead of a problem let's say
yeah i'm going to get around this
yeah there's always a way around it
maybe you can get a mortgage host
guarantor
maybe you can go get a job for three
months at mcdonald's yeah that gives you
a slip
exactly you've got to get around
problems rather than letting it stop you
yeah look for the solution man always
look for the solution so
um trying for yourself with positive
people marvin is super positive yeah
um anyone that is i call them energy
thieves
people that come around you yeah you
just feel tired when they leave
oh thank god he's gone like get rid of
all that [ __ ] that's negative energy you
don't need that anyone that's gonna
constantly be a thorn what about this
what about that um
someone looking out for [ __ ] hundred
percent what about this what about that
but
not pointing out random negative stuff
well we can't do that maybe
get rid of all that [ __ ] yeah um and try
and push it forward man um
because from the outside looking in
from where from where i'm from you
wouldn't think you can get into property
it feels it feels like i'm a superior
club that you're not
that you just can't get into um
and it's not that it's really really
simple
if you've got that little bit of
information and you supply yourself
yeah sure if you go to an estate agent
they'll make you feel belittled
um they'll look down at you um
i go into states like this like i don't
look like i've got any money
i look like i've got my little dodgy
110s on i've got an army jacket on
so i've got in there now says like right
i want to buy his property
they're like okay we're buying that cash
they're like okay
right we've got to ask you um source of
funds it's like you will not do
you state agent yeah source of funds
well you know it's protocol this is not
protocol
but yeah cool no problems so where'd you
get the money from
i said drugs
stressful start squeezing the stress
because i'm sorry mr reed but um
yeah we can't really smooth are you mad
do you think i'm gonna come in there and
just tell you
sorry i mean you got a funny sense of
humor brother
yeah she [ __ ] squeezed the stress
ball that was amazing
um i bet she believed you as well she
believed me yeah but but
but the one in their back she clocked
what was going on and she's
ah but estate agents aren't meant to ask
you about source of funds like um
that's your solicitor's job to ask you
for source of funds um
purplebricks another nightmare as well
um i'll put an offering on how to have a
down purple bricks
and pebble bricks throw me up and go
have you got a mortgage offer in place
i was like no i haven't go well until
you get a mortgage offer in place the
the seller's not prepared to entertain
your offer i was like one minute
so let me just get it straight so you
want me to go to a bank get a mortgaging
principle sorted out
to get an offer that i'm not even too
sure if it's going to be accepted
so yeah so i messaged the message to my
people it's me mate it's me purplebricks
are wankers
yeah when you when you finally realize
you can't sell your house with
purplebricks give me a shout
but the office one said that you know
i'm not you know i mean not this
dodgy estate agents man um they can [ __ ]
up herself for you my mom and dad are
um yeah because they'll judge you say
yeah they judge you they'll judge you
based on
how you talk your age yeah and and your
persona
and and then and i have this all the
time you know i mean when i especially
started because when i started i was
very very young yeah they'd ask me
questions that they wouldn't ask
the next person coming in just because
of my age or the fact that i'm not
educated educated yeah it's stupid um my
mom and dad were
moving from london up to huntington as
well yeah um
so i told him to go and look at the
properties and whatnot so the front of
the estate agents and i told him that my
mom's yaps on and everything
she's told them this is the situation
yeah we've gotten off on a house
but they're in a chain and blah blah
blah
can we make an appointment for this she
went no you can't
not until you can give me a date so i
said one minute
you're not going to let my parents
that's funny statement you'll get my
parents come and look at a house
because they haven't got an exchange and
completion date on their property yet
because they're old
i mean but i could phone you up right
now and come along and
ask to view 10 of your properties are
you going to send that jill to send me
to show me around because you know that
i'm serious
you might take the piss and you're
making it difficult for people
that do this on a one-off like me and
you we know
they're going to be idiots in that but
if you if this is like you most people
buy property
once or twice in their life it knocks
your confidence yeah if you don't know
what the crack is i mean
we know it's a game yeah we know the
rules to the game yeah we know what to
say
yeah sometimes you're you'll take the
mick and have fun with them
but we know we know the crack but people
that don't that are just getting started
it's their first property can really be
crushed by that yeah
yeah it's not nice um and so when i say
we find a decent estate agents
another trick i saw as well really
terrible trick
every time i've completed a property i'm
going to keep some estate agents
i've gone in this is one state agent it
must happen at other places as well
i've gone in there and i'm waiting for
my keys and they always take long to
give me the keys
and there's always this dude in the back
of the estate agents
that seems to be commending the [ __ ] out
of the estate agents because
i don't know if it wasn't for you guys
man you don't get enough credit you
really do i
swear to god i think it's a ploy i think
every time they sell a house they have
this same conversation within the estate
agents
to try and make you not cut out the
estate agent because really and truly
in the sales of it all the like the
whole selling of it
you don't really need an estate agent
you just need to see on rightmove and
get
the offer accepted by the people's
solicitors hence purple bricks in theory
and you can whack it on right move yeah
there are platforms where you can do it
quite cheap
yeah really cheap um so the estate
agents seem to be
like really the right move that deserve
the praise right move deserve the praise
yeah
because potentially although i wouldn't
want to necessarily say that and
and upset estate agents because estate
agents have to be your best friend as an
investor
they do but i i appreciate the point
yeah as an investor
as an investor 100 um and you've got to
go look for the right deal with your
state agents
a good relationship is better than a
good deal yeah always um
always um like i had a conversation with
with our estate agents um we used one in
town they're really really good um
and i said to me look uh give me the
give me the bargains
but i'm going to be i'm going to be i'm
going to be a [ __ ] in it i'm not going
to be nice i'm going to give you the
you're going to tell me the bargain i'm
going to go 10 bags lower and hope
for a really good deal but they
understand that and he goes that's
really really smart because we see
anything
we'll we will let you know um they're
not trying to fleece me they're not
trying to xyz
i've got a really good um i've got a
really good deal on the
commissions of what they're going to be
charging i think they do it for eight
percent
on um for what they do and they do all
their management
that's great management side of things
yeah buy low rent high with a property
manager nearby
yeah that's right damn right man right
final pieces of advice someone wanting
to get started into property
doesn't know anything totally clueless
what the next steps watch your videos
educate yourself yeah i appreciate that
it's a real talk though
you can yeah before you go and do
anything let's say you was coming to the
music industry
you're going to go and buy a publishing
book because you're going to be a
publisher or do you go
to a successful publisher and say how
the [ __ ] did you do that bro
and if the publisher is willing to tell
you that's more than what there's more
than reading a book which has been
published there's probably a date
probably you're probably not going to
get it in your head the way it's meant
to be you could read it wrong
um maybe not just maybe somebody else
which which you can understand
um somewhere that you can process all
the information
understand it and apply it um
[Music]
yeah that's what i'll say get it
appreciate that and you know what i also
appreciate you coming on
because i think you know you've you've
been successful music industry navy's
it's in property
[ __ ] a lot of rich people or successful
people hide away because they don't want
to get haters or they don't want to get
you know people come and ask them for
money but i really appreciate you coming
out and sharing i'm sure you'll
inspire a lot of people i appreciate it
so uh look forward to keeping in touch
definitely i'll be helping you out doing
some bigger things in development i'm
sure we'll have a part two next year
yeah be cool man and
uh bite the bullet and get a builder
absolutely man thanks again for coming
on the show
for my cheers nobody makes it from my
hands
i had to bust out the silence you know
you gotta stick by me
as soon as you see the text reply me i
don't wanna spend time fighting